resumes don't cut it anymore okay it
sucks it sucks it sucks it sucks hello
everybody my name is Nia and I'm the
black female engineer I provide C for
new and aspiring software engineers and
today we are talking about building your
personal brand for 2025 Corporate
America because that is really what is
going to take now to elevate your career
get that job get that promotion and be
seen as a person who can get the job
done so let's get right into to it I
became a software engineer back in 2020
after going to a coding boot camp I had
had a finance background and was like
you know what this isn't for me but I
believe software engineering is and I
was right that being said however
because I knew I was at a disadvantage
not having a computer science degree I
needed to establish myself as someone
who knows their and to do that I
started posting on platforms like
LinkedIn and medium at least weekly I
would go on LinkedIn and talk about what
I learned what projects I'm creating and
try to make connections wherever I could
with people working in the jobs that I
would like to work at on medium also
about on a weekly basis I would post an
article about something technical
something that I just did I remember I
did an article about I think it was
using some like was it graphql or some
type of API to integrate graphing into
one of the apps I had created so I
basically provided a whole tutorial for
how I did did that but if I had gotten
the computer science degree in 2020 and
was now looking for a job I never would
have even thought to do those things I
was doing those things purely out of
being at a disadvantage but I'm here to
tell you that now in good Lords 2025 you
need to do it too degree boot camp self-
teing and I'm going to make a grand
statement that no matter what industry
you're in if you're in Corporate America
your brand needs to pretty much be the
same thing and that is a person who
knows their if I'm in marketing I
need to be a marketing girlly that knows
what she's talking about if I'm in Tech
I'm a person that needs to show that I
am knowledgeable on all the emerging
Tech and Trends and so when I say
building a brand for Corporate America I
mean that how can people look at you and
say oh that person over there oh oh oh
they know their so for this we're
going to need to focus on two things
your online presence and your physical
presence starting with your online
presence that is your social media
platforms this being one of them we're
on YouTube that's one Tik Tok Instagram
LinkedIn medium substack there's so many
of them we need to start posting um the
whole time of feeling cringed out or shy
when it comes to content and things like
that that is back gone like anyone who
thinks that making content is cringe
they're the weird ones and the again
good Lords 2025 so if that is the thing
that's going to stop you from continuing
on this video and this path and doing
these things do not let it be because
now you're going to be the cringey one
thinking that this is cringe okay let me
calm down a little bit I get passionate
what's really great is with the tools I
mentioned there's kind of something for
I'm not going to say everybody but
something that's more easily digestible
for each type of Creator right there's
long form video content that I just
mentioned there's long form written
content there's short form video content
and short form written content so with
that in mind let's think about what we
would be most comfortable with and it
may seem obvious to some like oh
obviously I would do short form content
or obviously I would do written because
then you're not seeing my face but
actually because all of us have
different skill sets and different
things that make us uncomfortable we
would probably be shocked and actually
may you please please please let me know
in the comments I want to see if I'm
right about this please put in the
comments what even if you don't do this
at all what platform you would be most
comfortable posting on if you had to had
to had to it is the law now to start
posting content which platform would you
want to do that on start with one
platform which ever one you're most
comfortable with and dive deep on it I'm
going to get into what diving deep means
with the different platforms for example
posting once a week on YouTube is fine
meanwhile you need to post way more than
once a week on Tik talk so we're going
to go into that soon however I do want
to first talk about what you're going to
be posting when it comes to content we
can post a million different things
however let's try to think about what
would be best for getting you to the
goal that we want to get to which is
people seeing you as a thought leader as
knowledgeable Etc so each time we post
content let's think about these three
buckets one what is something that we
saw recently whether in the news or just
a trend that we're seeing what do we
think about those things to be a thought
leader you we need to have thoughts
right right so what do we think about
this new thing that's one two what are
you doing right now in your current work
that made you think made you learn
something new or it's something that you
would just like more people to know
about for example something I've worked
on in the past is seeing how accessible
the digital assets my team
had were let's say I'm looking at a page
on my computer can I navigate through
that page using just my keyboard that is
an accessibility issue and so I was put
on a task to really look at all of these
and then also now fix them I can create
a LinkedIn post or medium article titled
six accessibility pitfalls companies are
landing into with their web pages now
I've just turned my work experience into
something that is valuable for a lot
more people not just because it's
valuable what I did did but now people
can learn from me right we want to teach
people here and the third bucket
something more micro allows to see what
a day in your shoes looks like that's
why Day in the Life content is so so
captivating for a lot of us because it
allows us to just kind of like live in
someone else's shoes for a little bit
and so when we can provide that micro
content of saying hey let me do a quick
post whether it be video or a LinkedIn
post or whatever on timestamps of what I
did the entire day it can provide
someone insight as to what they can
expect their day to be like if they had
your job and that's something I love
doing whenever I'm going through either
career switch or pivot I love seeing hey
what can I expect in a role like this
and would I actually like the day byday
or do I just think I would like it based
on my own preconceived notions and so
you may not think that going through
your day byday like that is valuable but
it is and here are some other content
ideas that should be applicable to you
no matter industry remember when I said
we would talk about what diving deep
means for these different platforms well
here we go just like I mentioned before
diving deep on YouTube is one piece of
content a long form video about 7 to 15
minutes long at least you can definitely
go way more than that every single week
obviously it comes with its own time
constraints and things like that but
that is an approach with Tik Tok and
Instagram I would give you the pass at
five videos every week there's lots of
people who would say you need to post
three times a day five times a day Etc
on Tik Tok and one time every single day
on Instagram to actually grow your
audience however I have seen that as
long as you're providing value five
times a week is actually quite great
because the think about building our
brand for corporate is value matters way
more than anything else when it comes to
oh make sure you turn out this Mona that
matters a lot less for this reason on
LinkedIn about three posts a week with
be fantastic quick tip though in 2025
LinkedIn is prioritizing video content
like no other and so if you can do a mix
of text form content and video content
that would be great and video content on
LinkedIn is the exact same as Tik Tok
and Instagram just a horizontal video
about 60 seconds and I'm medium and
substack posting an article a couple
times a week would be phenomenal
wherever you decide to live for the next
year however May make sure that that
platform has a fantastic bio think to
yourself what do I want to be known for
I provide content for new inlying
software Engineers that is a tagline
right there make sure that that tagline
is in each of your bios on each of your
platforms make it easy for someone to
think of you the way you want to be
thought about and the way to do that is
to tell them how to think about you you
know so that's online presence now let's
talk about physical presence okay come
here
yes come here come here I'mma hold your
hand while I say this we need to go
outside anyway we got to we got to and
maybe this is no problem for y'all and I
really I'm holding my own hand because
I'm not a person who goes outside people
who know me know that very well but we
need to go outside y'all companies want
to hire and bring on people who make
sure that they are keeping up with
emerging Tech and Trends and I we
already talked about this that's part of
the reason we're doing but another way
to show that you care about that is by
physically putting yourself in
environments where emerging Tech and
Trends is being talked about the two
main areas conferences and Industry
events even if it's not as big as a
conference industry events try your best
your best in 2025 cuz we're we'll start
are small okay go to one big conference
one conference that is nationally
recognized big probably cost some money
however if you're currently working you
can get your employer to send you there
and if you're not you can likely deduct
it from your taxes however do I am not a
tax professional I left accounting and
finance so do not take this as law okay
but you can likely deduct at least
partially those expenses on your tax
returns go to to at least one nationally
recognized conference and try to go to
two other events just in your industry
but can be smaller can be free can be a
small group of people no bells and
whistles necessary just something to
really get yourself deep into your
community the community of your industry
talk to people connect with people after
you go to those events post about what
you learned at those events it's just
going to be a loop after loop after Loop
and that is how we establish ourselves
as a thought leader and cement our
personal brand as being a knowledgeable
reliable person in XNX industry rumes
don't cut it anymore okay it sucks it
sucks it sucks it sucks I feel like
about two years ago we started seeing
this but we're kind of like crossing our
fingers that's not true and last year
was awful awful awful rumes don't cut it
anymore this is what you need to get a
job grow in your job grow in your field
grow in your industry this is what is
needed and I don't see it going away
anytime soon I only see it getting more
and more necessary so please do not make
it harder on yourself in 2026 and 2027
when you're seeing your entire team
posting Day in the Life videos and here
you are wondering why you're not getting
the promotion okay sorry I don't mean I
don't mean to you but please okay help
me help you let's do this let's get it
on
well you know and the truth is I can go
on and on for a very long time talking
about this so if there's any aspect of
this you'd like me to dive deeper on I
beg of you put it in the comments that
way I know which things to really focus
on in the part twos and threes of this
video but thank you so much for watching
happy
2025 and I am so excited to see yall
soon